And this is very exciting.
And I did not realize this.
Your daughter is in town
this week because she is
on "Young Sheldon."
-That's right.
-She's an actress.
-Yes.
-And she plays Young Sheldon's
mother -- which is crazy because
you play Old Sheldon's mother.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That is -- I had no idea --
-This can't have
ever happened anywhere --
-It can never have happened.
-I know that mothers and
daughters have played mothers
and daughters, and maybe
they've played the same person
in a flashback, maybe.
-Yeah.
-But this is on two
concurrently running shows.
-Yeah.
-Both Mary Cooper.
-Yeah, and two,
like, different timelines.
-Yeah.
-It's insane.
So -- it's been fun.
Now that "Young Sheldon" exists,
when I do go in every once
in a while to do a "Big Bang,"
it really -- I look at --
I look at Jim differently.
I know him now as the little boy
on "Young Sheldon" and
the other kids on the family
that they've cast.
It's just been --
-So, you're retroactively --
-There's layers upon layers.
-Yes, I am. I am.
-That's fantastic.
-So, congratulations
on your Tony nomination.
This is a fantastic --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Fantastic cast.
Glenda Jackson, Allison Pill.
Were you familiar with the play
when you signed on to do it?
-I had never done an
Edward Albee play before.
I had always heard
the title "Three Tall Women,"
had never read it,
and signed on to do it blind
because I wanted to be in
the room with Joe Mantello,
the director, Glenda Jackson,
the legend, Allison Pill, oh --
who I've been dying to work
with, and also the producer,
Scott Rudin, who,
you know, is --
-He knows what he's doing.
-Yes, he does.
Yes.
-And this is --
I did not realize this about
Glenda Jackson, your co-star.
So, she won two Oscars
and then she went
into Parliament.
-Walked away from --
-And then was in Parliament
for 23 years.
-Ran for Parliament.
Lost the first time, I think.
Ran again.
Served for 23 years.
Left that and then decided
to get back into theater
and decided to do "King Lear."
She played "King Lear"
in London.
-Wow.
[ Light laughter ]
-So, she -- she jumped
right back in again.
And -- now she's on Broadway
starring in this.
And she's fantastic.
-Is it intimidating to work
with someone like that
or do you just learn from it
and is it wonderful?
-Well, I thought that
I had pretty good stamina
'cause I've been doing theater
for a long time.
You do the eight shows a week
and I think Glenda could do,
like, a circus performer.
I think that she could literally
do about 13 shows a week.
You know, just stack 'em up.
Three shows a day.
She has fantastic stamina.
She's got that voice
that carries to
the back row and beyond.
-What an awesome thing
to be around.
-Yeah.
-You -- you also found out,
and congratulations.
You were nominated for an Oscar
this year for "Ladybird,"
in which you were fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And -- and I know
they're going to do a prequel
of "Ladybird," and your daughter
is going to play the mom again.
-Yeah, probably. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But -- so, you found out
the first day of rehearsal that
you were nominated for an Oscar.
Does that affect how you prepare
for a play on the first day?
Getting, sort of --
-You know, well,
I'll just always remember
it as this fantastic day.
These kind of days don't happen.
My favorite place to be is in a
rehearsal room on the first day
of rehearsal and start --
open up the script
and everybody's around the table
and you know you're really going
to dig in and start the work.
I love that.
And that morning,
the Oscar nominations came out.
So, when those two came together
on the same day, I mean,
how good does that get?
-Yeah, that's really good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Really well deserved.
You have -- you've been doing
theater for a very long time.
As you mentioned, you were one
of the founding members of
the Steppenwolf troupe
in Chicago.
I was lucky enough to see shows
there when I lived there.
Here you guys are.
This is a younger --
people might not recognize.
There's young John Malkovich,
there.
-Mm-hmm.
-Gary Sinise, there.
And you were all, pretty much,
actors of the same age
when you started it, yeah?
-Right, right, right.
Right.
-And did that make it hard to
figure out who was playing what?
-Yeah.
You can't find too many plays
that have two, four, six,
eight -- eight actors
of the same age.
-Yeah.
-You know, we ran out quickly.
So what we had to do
was play roles that
we'd never get cast in before.
So, like, I would play
John Malkovich's mother
in "True West," and then I would
bounce around and play
his niece -- 13-year-old niece
in "Fifth of July."
There's Jeff Perry, too.
Joan Allen.
And -- and, so, we got --
we got better that way.
We challenged ourselves,
and our audiences in Chicago
rolled with us, you know,
they were really supportive.
They were taken aback at some
of the choices that we did,
but they -- they stuck with us.
-You -- obviously, you have your
responsibilities as an actor
onstage, but you're also helping
run this theater company?
Was that a difficult time
or was that alt-thrilling?
-It was -- it was fun.
We just thought
we would do it for a summer.
-Uh-huh.
-And now I think we're in our
45th season, I'm not sure.
-Unbelievable.
-But we were in a
little church basement up
in Highland Park, Illinois.
Everybody just wanted to direct.
Nobody -- I mean, everybody
wanted to act and be on stage.
Nobody wanted to direct.
So, that was the -- the job that
somebody every once in a while
had to take and also clean the
bathrooms and tear the tickets.
-Gotcha.
I did not realize this,
but I've seen --
I've seen your name in the past
listed as a former cast member
of "Saturday Night Live."
In turns out,
you did two things.
In 1981 -- that's -- it's very
hard to even tell it's you.
You did a 'Man on the Street"
bit in 1981.
-Yeah.
-And then you did a piece
with Catherine O'Hara,
a short film
which is called
"Laurie Has a Story,"
which I watched today,
and it's fantastic.
-Yeah.
-Do you have any memory of it?
-I -- that's funny that
you should say that.
It is like a dream.
I see that there's proof.
There's proof
that I did do these things.
But in '81, you know, I --
Tim Kazurinsky..
-Yes, from Chicago as well.
-...brought me on --
or, suggested that I come on
and have a tryout.
And so, they put me in
that oversized suit
with a small little crew,
and threw me out onto the street
to say, "Would you take
a bullet for the President?"
-Uh-huh.
-And pretty soon that --
There was a little crowd
around us, you know.
I didn't know what I was --
I'd never been to New York.
-Uh-huh.
-I didn't know where I was,
what I was doing.
-That is such a terr--
That is the worst casting --
-The actor's nightmare.
Right, yeah.
-That's worse than you as
a 13-year-old niece.
-Right, right, right.
-But, it was so exciting.
I -- well, I want --
I'll make sure you can see it,
'cause you gotta go back
and watch this.
It was really --
really fun to watch.
And Doug McGrath,
who's a wonderful guy,
was also in that sketch,
as well.
So such an honor
to have you here.
I'm such a fan.
Thank you so much.